(lively music)
- [Narrator] In the town of
Grindelwald in Switzerland,
people like sledding and
heading to the ski slopes.
After all, they are at the
foot of the Eiger Mountain,
part of the stunning Swiss Alps.
But if you look close enough,
you'll see something else,
something different
coming down the slopes.
It's the Velogemel.
- [Narrator] This odd bike quickly became
part of the town's identity.
And over 100 years later,
it is still used for
leisure sledding and racing.
- [Narrator] Grindelwald is
the birthplace of Velogemels.
And to day this day, they're
only manufactured in one place,
which means if you're riding one,
it came from this workshop,
where despite the addition
of modern machinery,
the principals of its
construction remain the same.
(elegant music)